30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
fear on the App Store or Google Play
weight training is extremely essential
to your overall workout program when
done correctly weight training can help
you lose fat increase your metabolism to
burn more calories increase your
strength and muscle tone increase bone
density and improve your overall
appearance ladies if you want to achieve
the toned and strong look you got to
ditch at the cardio machine and start
lifting weights I do understand that it
can get very confusing and overwhelming
to some so I'm gonna share with you the
six principles to increase muscle to
lean up and lose weight first technique
I've always emphasized on proper form
and technique
having good technique when exercising is
extremely important because only then
will you be able to achieve better
results target the right muscles and
you're less likely to hurt yourself so
unless you suffer from a previous injury
you will always want to execute the full
range of motion in an exercise to
recruit the entire targeted muscle for
instance if you were to perform a half
squat instead of a full squat you will
not fully recruit your quads glutes and
hamstrings hence you're not training at
your optimum let's look at the mind-body
connection it is important to focus your
mind on the targeted muscle when
performing an exercise if you're a
beginner you may struggle with this
initially for instance when performing a
chest press instead of filling the chest
muscles you will feel more on your
shoulders this will take time but you
got to keep telling your mind to focus
on that particular chest muscle and
eventually you will start to create the
mind-body connection
second mechanical tension mechanical
tension is the primary stimulus for
muscle growth during strength training
muscles experience stretching forces
when they try to shorten but are
resisted when they do so they also
experience stretching forces when they
lengthen
while we are holding a load but these
forces are comparatively
if your focus is to increase strength
then the weights must be heavy enough
for you to only perform between four to
six repetitions max and keep between two
to five minutes rest interval however if
your focus is muscle hypertrophy or
muscle growth then the weights must be
heavy enough for you to perform between
6 to 12 rep max per set and take between
60 to 90 seconds rest interval if you
can lift more than your aunt lifting
heavy enough you've got to add on more
weights yes ladies you've got to lift
heavy to increase strength and lean up
and no it will not make you bulky but
muscle fatigue you got to feel like if
push yourself hard enough and in fact
you should train to failure what does
that mean muscle failure during strength
training is the point at which fatigue
is high enough to prevent a muscle from
exerting at the amount of force needed
to complete the current repetition with
the given load if doing another
repetition is possible you haven't
reached muscle failure the objective is
to induce the most possible muscle
growth by pumping maximum blood to the
area another way to target muscle
fatigue is to increase the volume per
muscle group this is basically
calculated based on the number of
exercises for one muscle group
multiplied by the number of sets for
each exercise for instance if we were to
work on our glutes and perform three
exercises hip thrusts Romanian deadlift
and kickbacks and we were to do three
sets for each workout the volume for the
workout will be three exercises
multiplied by three sets which means
nine a good volume to increase muscle
growth is between six to ten the volume
of exercise per muscle group is to be
gradually progressed according to your
training capability fourth principle
eccentric training an eccentric movement
is the lowering part of a move it's when
your muscle works as its lengthened for
example when you're lowering into a
squat or as you're lowering your arms in
a bicep curl the
or pushing of the weight would be
concentric eccentric training is much
more demanding on the muscles and
therefore if it takes them far more than
you could concentric Li this promotes
greater muscle damage greatest
stimulation and muscle growth as a
general rule of thumb for eccentric
training take 4 to 5 seconds to lower
the weight for instance take 4 seconds
to lower into a squat to lower the bar
to your chest or to lower the dumbbells
during a shoulder press
this then leads on to my next point
repetition tempo I'm sure you must have
come across some workout programs with
four digits written on them some of you
might be wondering what does each number
represent the first number represents
eccentric face followed by transition
concentric face and followed by
isometric why is this important
let's first understand time under
tension or more commonly referred to as
tu tee time under tension is the time
your muscle spends under load during a
set this includes the time spent in the
concentric isometric and eccentric face
for example if you perform at a mihrab
set and each rep only takes 3 seconds to
complete your muscle experiences 30
seconds of time under tension now if you
were to perform the same set but spend
two seconds lifting the weight one
second isometric and three seconds
lowering the weight then those same 10
reps would give you approximately 60
seconds of time under tension even
though the rep count stayed the same the
muscle spent significantly more time
under tension and that extra time
actually translates to a lot more work
remember
your muscle can't count they simply feel
the load created by the weight and the
mechanical pension that comes from
contracting the muscle under the load
therefore to increase the work done by
your muscles you can either increase the
load or increase at the time the muscle
is placed under this load here are some
of the common tempos used in a workout
program
and the final principle is recovery I'm
sure you might have come across some
people who would spend many hours in the
gym every single day
however spending more hours in the gym
does not equal to faster results because
your muscles need to recover in order to
grow and for you to trim at your optimum
level recovery can include stretching
right after a strength training session
during a lifting session the muscles you
use contract making them tighter not
stretching your muscles may lead to
decrease in range of motion and
flexibility which may also lead to
long-term injuries regular stretching
helps to increase circulation and
maintain flexibility so that you can
continue to train at your best recovery
also includes filling your body with
enough high-quality food no matter how
hard you train or how heavy you lift if
your diet is crap you're pretty much
wasting your efforts in the gym so make
sure you feed your muscles with enough
lean proteins cups vegetables and
healthy fats you will also need to
schedule in your rest days to avoid
overtraining so check in with yourself
consistently and ask yourself how's your
energy level how's it your stress level
and how's the sleep quality all these
would have a direct effect to your
recovery another important point is to
avoid under eating or consuming too
little carbs yes you may want to reduce
on your cups but your bodies still need
cups for energy if you're on an
extremely low carb diet that's when your
energy level dips your stress level
increases and this will also affect your
sleep and training if you have been
doing regular strength training and you
would like to improve or if you have hit
a plateau and struggled to progress then
incorporate these tips if you find that
you are learning from my videos and then
be sure to hit the subscribe button ok
share this video on give me a thumbs up
and be sure to check out other videos on
my channel from workout videos
nutritional tips fitness
tips as well as healthy recipes are the
best